it's great to welcome to the program
today Roger Hallam who's a British
environmental activist and co-founder of
extinction rebellion a movement that
uses nonviolent civil disobedience to
compel government action on climate
change
Roger it's so great to have you on I
appreciate it yeah great friends so this
is a topic I'm very interested in
because I've long argued that here in
the United States for example calling
your elected official and signing a
petition online is very rarely going to
really achieve the kind of systemic
change that we need in order to deal
with some of the major issues that are
facing us climate change and
environmental issues certainly included
and I know that for me violent civil
disobedience feels like it is over the
line but finding exactly where the line
is is maybe more complicated than some
might think so can you talk a little bit
about your perspective in some of the
protests you've organized well the first
thing to say is as I'm sure people know
and the climate change crisis has been
going on now for 30 years since 1990
when scientists first told people they
were heading for this massive
catastrophe if something isn't doesn't
happen so as you write you say people
been sending emails and lobbying and and
doing all the conventional stuff for 30
years and carbon emissions have gone up
by 60% which is beyond bad as as
everyone knows so you know extinction
rebellion came along will you with a
black sheet of paper a bit like what you
said and said okay so that's not working
so what needs to work and the fact of
the matter is is civil disobedience does
work as long as it's constructed in a
particular way and just to sort of
expand on that civil disobedience is a
way of peacefully breaking the law they
involves respect towards your opponent
so it's really a little bit complicated
to get your head round because obviously
you're disrupting people's lives and the
government but the same time you're
saying look we want to talk and we want
to sort this problem out and that's
really wasting some rebelling is about
and what civil disappearance is about
can you talk a little bit about some
the tactics and techniques that that you
use yeah the main the main way of
disrupting governments I guess is to sit
in a road some people paint building
some people go on hunger strike none of
this is what people want to do I hasten
to add right it's not the sort of thing
you take do lightly but thousands of
people around the world have now made a
decision because the pennies drop that
nothing else is working and that's the
thing that gets the disruption those two
things going on you're disrupting people
but also people are impressed by your
sacrifice people work you know getting
arrested going to prison and
what-have-you and obviously no one does
that lightly so people don't tend to
think even if they disagree with you it
I think at least a go well you know the
guy is actually standing by way believes
and so maybe there's something to what
he's saying so that's really how it
works
do we have data as to what the public
perception is of some of these actions
because for example in the United States
we've had a number of different protests
that involved shutting down a bridge
which is a key commuting artery into or
out of a city and at least anecdotally a
lot of the reaction seems to be I need
to go to work and if I'm not there I get
fired I can no longer feed my kids and
it's it's in a sense of violent act
against my ability to put food on my
family's table so I wonder what the
reaction do we have anything empirical
about how people do react when they hear
about such a protest that is it for
example a blocking the road protest well
the first thing to say is you know it's
very no-brainer
obviously it's totally maddening if
someone's stopping you getting to work
so no one's trying to dispute that the
point of civil disobedience is you're
taking responsibility you're not trying
to run away from your actions it's not
like you're blocking the road and then
running off you're basically saying to
people I'm blocking a road I know I'm
acting illegally and I'm more prepared
I'm prepared to go to court and you know
suffer for why I've done I'm prepared to
get fined I'm prepared to go to prison
if needs be so that changes things a
little bit but in terms of how it
the public like what we need to look at
is like the public as a whole and I can
give you an interesting stat for
instance but what happened last year if
you want some specific data on it like
most people in Britain hadn't really
heard of the climate emergency a bit
like in America everyone thought it was
a little bit of a small problem but
actually it's a massive problem and
1,200 people were arrested last April it
was the biggest civil disobedience in
British history
and after that the episode 67% of the
British population agreed there was a
climbing emergency in other words I was
like tens of millions of conversations
in pubs you know around kitchen tables
where people were going and going a
minute
there's thousands people getting
arrested this is a big issue we sort of
knew it was a big issue and now we know
it's a big issue and that's how attitude
change works so in other words even if
at the micro level someone is prevented
from getting to work as an example if
the social consciousness rises to the
point where you have critical mass
towards action you you consider it a net
benefit that's that's what happens on a
social level yeah but it has to be done
in a respectful way and this is the
thing that people often forget this
isn't like just without rioting or about
being sort of aggressive or what have
you it's calm is order disrespectful and
then as I said even if people disagree
with you they certainly have a you know
a certain respect for you putting
yourself on the line and I think the
other thing we need to understand is
that civil just being it's worked but it
only works if you're doing something on
an issue that's right you know if I sit
in a road and block you getting to work
and I want you to wear a red hat for me
or something you're gonna say I don't
care that you're sitting in the road you
know no way am I going to do that for
you it only really works when everyone
knows it's actually real you know this
is objectively real what's happening
with the climate crisis and this is the
biggest problem is communicating that
we're absolutely in this dire situation
and that's why people are taking this
you know dramatic step one of the
tactics that seems to be more of a gray
area for differ
activists depending on where they draw
the line is the destruction of for
example imagine that you're protesting
logging going in the middle of the night
so nobody gets hurt and disabling or
damaging bulldozers as an example its
destruction of property certainly it's
certainly a crime but no one is being
physically hurt where is something like
that in your sort of paradigm well to be
honest with you like the old sort of way
of doing direct action as far as I'm
concerned and I've done five years of
research at King's College in London on
it the main way to change society is
through mass participation civil
disobedience which means like tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
people breaking the law in a small way
in urban centres where everyone can see
them where that's where the government
is was the media and what-have-you in
other words you go to the capital city
and this sort of thing has been
happening in in many countries of the
world for the last 50 years particularly
the global south well you know you've
probably seen a psychic in Algeria or
Sudan or many other countries people go
to the capital city and say we don't
want to live under a dictatorship under
corruption anymore and we're sitting
down until we get some semblance of
democracy so we're really we're
borrowing that methodology from those
people and applying it twisting
democracies where we have this corrupt
situation of governments listening to
fossil fuel companies a lot more to
ordinary citizens who are concerned
about their children's future so that's
really what we're aiming for rather than
you know 10 people doing something in
the middle of the night as it were so in
other words it's less about figuring out
whether destruction of property is on
this side or that side of the line but
recognizing that that's too small in
action compared to the mass rally at an
urban centre to really achieve the sort
of attention that you believe is
necessary to get change to happen
yeah and it's not to be honest with you
primarily about the physical disruption
it's more about the emotional
communication you know when you see
someone who's 84 or a kid who's 14
getting dragged off by the police
they're not enough it immediately has a
emotional reaction you know whether you
opposed to it or not you're thinking
what's going on
you know and when normal people come out
on the streets and this is what it's all
about it's not about activists or
whatever you know I'm sure I'm a farmer
I've been doing growing food for people
for thirty years now and it's normal
people that are starting to take the
initiative here rather than what you
might call the old activist communities
and that's the difference with
extinction rebellion is it's bringing up
people from lots of different politics
and cultural backgrounds you know from
small business people you know single
mothers you know people from all
different backgrounds to saying hang on
a minute this is a universal issue which
affects everything that I believe in you
know whether you've got right-wing
values or left-wing values right no one
wants to see the destruction of America
right is that right I think so for the
most part I think that's true yeah and
that's why I'm coming to America to do
you know I'm promoting my book common
sense it's called common sense because
it's related to Thomas Paine I don't
know you know Thomas Paine because
America in the revolution you said to
Americans you know you're not going to
get rid of the British unless you just
have a revolution and say no we don't
want the British crown anymore and what
I'm saying to the American public is you
need to deal with this directly by
having thousands of people on the street
saying we don't actually want the
destruction of our families or
communities and the American nation
that's fundamentally what what this is
about no question and we've been talking
about the importance of mass rallies at
urban centers as a tool for achieving
change for years on the program Roger
Hallam is a British environmental
activist co-founder of extinction
rebellion author of common sense
Rogers such a pleasure having you on and
I appreciate you sharing your
perspective yeah well thank you good
luck